[Music]
yep Jenna Bush Hager is gonna be a mom
for the third time yo and I'm very
pregnant well I don't know how I had
missed the 37 year old shared the news
on The Today Show Monday morning after
revealing it to her daughter's
six-year-old Amelia and three-year-olds
papi on Easter Sunday and I'm only
coming because Mila and pop we found out
yesterday in the Easter basket there's
no keeping a secret hold the man behind
me on the airplane they told the people
at church Jenna says she's nearly six
months along which means she's been
keeping this a secret since before she
was named a Kathie Lee Gifford's
replacement on the fourth hour of the
morning show
I told Hoda and I was really worried
about it cuz we're starting this new
show right and I told Hoda and I said
I'm so sorry and she kind of had a
glimmer in her eye and lo and behold yes
Jenna's big announcement comes less than
a week after her today co-host toda copy
reveals that she had adopted a second
child in just weeks after the pair
relaunched the fourth hour of the show
well I just feel so lucky I really do
I am surrounded with people I love I
work with people I love and I have two
little girls who light up my life and a
husband that supports me unconditionally
so like I think therapy I can't stop
you